[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- We have a confession
and 20 eyewitnesses.
- And knife wounds
all over the place.
- Her drug test is clear, no
history of mental illness.
- We've got everything
except for why.
Did you hear her say anything?
- It's like she's someone else.
- He didn't try to stop her.
- The mind plays tricks.
You see things
that aren't there.
- Tell us anything,
whatever you can.
- I think there's
something wrong with me.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
JESSICA BIEL: Hello.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, so
please welcome to the stage
Jessica Biel.
JESSICA BIEL: Hello.
ALAN SEALES: Have a seat.
JESSICA BIEL: Hi.
ALAN SEALES: And we just
watched episode one,
everyone who's here.
I want to quickly touch on
the actual murder scene,
because I saw the whole
audience squirm and--
JESSICA BIEL: Good.
ALAN SEALES: --bite their nails
and do all sorts of things.
Is that the normal reaction
that you get from us?
JESSICA BIEL: Yeah.
I actually haven't watched the
show with many big audiences
before.
ALAN SEALES: Really?
JESSICA BIEL: Well
it's rare, I think,
to have a television show that
you get to screen like this.
It's new.
Just went to the Tribeca
Film Fest last year,
but that's a new thing.
Usually you're
bringing films there.
You're not usually
bringing shows there.
So I haven't seen this
more than a few times
with a larger crowd.
But yes, it's always a
bit of a cringe moment
because it comes out of nowhere,
which is the idea, right,
is the idea that
this person is just
kind of blacking and having
this sort of attack almost.
And yeah, everybody cringes.
And it's over really
fast, which is
kind of another part
of the whole idea
that when violence
occurs in life,
it doesn't always have this
long, dramatic experience.
It's like boom and it's
done, and no one even
knows what's happened.
ALAN SEALES: So
what was the impetus
to screen it at festivals?
Because you said it's
a new thing, right?
JESSICA BIEL: Well
for the festival
it's a new thing I mean.
To I think only last--
sorry, the year we were,
which is last year,
so the year before
that, I feel like that's
the first time that the Tribeca
Film Festival started screening
shows.
So for the film
festivals I believe
it's kind of a new thing.
So when you're doing
a TV show and then you
get to go to a film
festival, first of all,
it's kind of surprising
and exciting.
And then you go and you see the
show that you've been making,
but you've never expected
to see it on a huge screen.
You expect it to
just be on TV, small.
ALAN SEALES: These
are just big TVs.
JESSICA BIEL: I know,
But it's different.
It just seems different somehow.
ALAN SEALES: Does that mean
that you filmed the pilot
a long time ago and then
you just picked up two
through eight recently?
JESSICA BIEL: Yeah,
not too long ago.
We filmed it in the fall.
I think it was the fall.
ALAN SEALES: I guess what
I'm asking is normally you
film a pilot, it gets greenlit.
You have to screen
it and what not,
see if there's interest in it.
It may or may not ever air.
Did you go into it knowing
you would make the full eight
episodes?
JESSICA BIEL: No, we
did what you just said.
So we developed the material.
We got a writer on
board, Derek Simonds,
who then wrote
the pilot and what
the bible for what the
show would look like.
Not necessarily how many
episodes it would be,
because we didn't quite know.
It can change when
you eventually
sell it to the right place.
And they have a lot of opinions
about, is it eight, is it ten,
is it only like a two hour
thing two nights in a row?
So we wrote the pilot, and
then we pitched it around.
And USA was interested.
And so basically that's
when they bought--
sorry, so then they gave us
the money to film the pilot.
ALAN SEALES: Money's important.
JESSICA BIEL: That's
what we needed, right?
Money's important sometimes.
And then we showed
them the pilot.
And then they picked up
the rest of the season.
So it's possible we would
have just shot the pilot
and no one ever saw it again.
ALAN SEALES: Because
I was reading,
two through eight-- this is an
eight part miniseries for those
of you who don't figure out what
I'm talking about are ready.
You know what the end will be.
You know you're not going
to a season two, right?
JESSICA BIEL: No,
not necessarily.
ALAN SEALES: Ooh.
[LAUGHTER]
JESSICA BIEL: I mean,
television is so cool.
The idea was sort of it
could be anthology series.
What we want to do with season
one is we will close the case.
So you're not going to
be season two going, ugh,
I still have to wait
to get the answer.
We're going to
close out this case
and you're going to
understand what happened.
We're going to give
you all the answers.
Season two, if Bill
is interested--
Bill Pullman I'm talking
about obviously--
he can take on a new case.
And I don't want to give away
what the ending's going to be,
but there is a possibility
that maybe my character
could be involved in some way.
But I don't think that's really
giving away much, necessarily.
ALAN SEALES: But we know that
you're involved in this case.
JESSICA BIEL: Yes,
I'm definitely
involved in this case.
Or you could recast
the whole thing.
ALAN SEALES: "True Detectives."
JESSICA BIEL: Right, or
"American Horror Story,"
or put characters
in other positions.
You could do a lot of things.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, and you
would be interested in that
from the executive
producer standpoint--
JESSICA BIEL: Well yeah.
ALAN SEALES: --not from
the acting standpoint.
JESSICA BIEL: Well
from both, bu yeah,
definitely from the
producer standpoint I would
love my actors to come back.
ALAN SEALES: So is this the
first time you've executive
produced anything or is
this old hat for you?
JESSICA BIEL: Well I produced a
film with my producing partner
Michelle Purple and my
small little tiny company
called Iron Ocean just this past
year called "The Book of Love."
We produced a small short film.
So this is my first
television producing.
ALAN SEALES: And how is it
different for you starring
in it and producing it?
JESSICA BIEL: Well it's just
kind of double duty, you know?
I have to wear a couple of hats.
But definitely when
I'm working on set,
on the days I'm
working on set, we
have a really good
team around us.
Like I mentioned before, my
producing partner Michelle
and Charlie Gogolak, another
one of our producers,
there's a lot of support there.
So they're kind of managing the
day to day producorial stuff.
And I can kind of focus
on the creative stuff.
ALAN SEALES: Producorial.
JESSICA BIEL: Producorial.
ALAN SEALES: I like that.
JESSICA BIEL: It's a hard job.
I'm not great at it.
I'm very good and I like
the creative producing.
I want to talk to writers.
I want to talk to actors.
I want to character develop,
story arc, character arc.
I want to do that
kind of producing.
And my partner has to do
all the horrible stuff.
ALAN SEALES: Well it
seems like the best--
JESSICA BIEL: It
works out for me.
ALAN SEALES: --you've got the
best of both worlds, yeah.
I'm going to quote
you for a second.
You said, "I've never
gotten a new romantic comedy
like most of the girls.
Maybe because I'm fit people
assume I'm not funny."
JESSICA BIEL: I said that?
ALAN SEALES: That's what--
JESSICA BIEL: I don't
think I said that.
ALAN SEALES: That's
what the internet said.
I googled it.
JESSICA BIEL: Well the
internet is always right.
ALAN SEALES: I googled it.
[LAUGHTER]
JESSICA BIEL: OK
let's go with it.
I'm fit, therefore
I'm not funny?
That's what it says?
No, don't repeat it.
Please God--
[APPLAUSE]
--I beg you.
Anyway, let's keep going.
I know where you're
going with this.
ALAN SEALES: So this is a very
dramatic role, very serious.
"Chainsaw Massacre,"
"7th Heaven," you
were in the third "Blade" with
Wesley Snipes, all of these
are not funny roles.
JESSICA BIEL: You're right.
ALAN SEALES: They're not even
air quotes, but funny roles.
They're actually not funny.
Do the roles seek you out or
do you seek out the roles?
JESSICA BIEL: No, this
is a very good question
because when you put it on
paper like that, I'm like,
what is wrong with me?
Why am I want to scare everybody
and be serious all the time?
Because I'm really not that
serious of a person actually.
So I don't know.
I think it must be a little
bit of both, somehow.
You know what it is?
I like to be scared, and I
like to watch dramatic thing,
I think.
Maybe that's what it is.
So if there's a cool
piece of material--
I'm just looking at it
is if it's something
that I would watch,
and then maybe I would
want to be in it or something.
Maybe that's it.
ALAN SEALES: So you don't
watch anything funny?
JESSICA BIEL: Well see,
that's not true either.
I mean, I watch
more dramatic stuff.
But of course I love to laugh.
I'm being really insecure
about this about myself.
[LAUGHTER]
I need to change
something about my life.
ALAN SEALES: All right, then I
will co-write a comedy and you
will--
JESSICA BIEL: Please.
Thank you.
ALAN SEALES: You'll
be first on my list.
JESSICA BIEL: I hope so.
ALAN SEALES: So there's
a tie-in obviously
with the book that is sitting
here with your picture on it.
Yeah, have you seen this?
JESSICA BIEL: I have seen that.
I think that looks pretty cool.
I never thought I'd be on
the cover of a book before.
Well I mean, it's a
little random, no?
ALAN SEALES: Well,
if you exec produce--
JESSICA BIEL: It's really cool.
ALAN SEALES: --something
based on a book, yeah.
JESSICA BIEL: I know, but do you
see people on books very often?
I don't.
Are you on a book?
ALAN SEALES: Me, no.
JESSICA BIEL: OK, I
thought you would be like,
well I'm on a book, so.
ALAN SEALES: Well yeah, I'm
on like six books, books
about how to interview badly.
JESSICA BIEL: I think
this is going quite well.
ALAN SEALES: Oh thank you.
JESSICA BIEL: I don't know.
Maybe I'm off.
ALAN SEALES: We're got a
few holes, so we're OK.
The series takes place in
Upstate New York, right?
JESSICA BIEL: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: Did you film
there, or where did you film
all the different outsides?
JESSICA BIEL: No.
We filmed our pilot in
Charleston, South Carolina,
which was so cool.
What a great place
to spend sometime.
But we did that because we could
sort of fake Upstate New York
at that time.
I mean listen, the
foliage is very different,
but we managed to
fake it a little bit.
We were dealing with a
time in the year issue.
And obviously you can see I was
in the water a decent amount.
And we were really worried about
being Upstate New York in--
I think it was October.
It's October we
were filming, so we
thought that's a little tricky,
little dicey, you never know.
Could be iced over and frozen.
It's possible.
So we filmed the pilot there.
And then everything else--
we're still filming.
I have to go back
to work tomorrow.
I have the day off today
to hang out with you guys.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah,
this is your day off.
This is my day off.
But I am not crying and sad and
miserable, which is basically
what I am a lot on this show.
[LAUGHTER]
We're not done with
the interview yet.
JESSICA BIEL: So good for me.
ALAN SEALES: Don't worry.
JESSICA BIEL: I
know that's true.
I'm getting ahead of myself.
So the rest of the episodes,
the rest of the seven
will be shot here.
And we're working here
and a lot of places
Upstate, kind of Nyack area
and other surrounding areas.
ALAN SEALES: So the
city that the story's
set in, totally fictional.
JESSICA BIEL: No, it's
not totally fictional.
I think it could
be like New Paltz.
Is that a fictional place?
I thought that was
an actual real place.
AUDIENCE: It's a real place.
ALAN SEALES: It's real?
OK.
JESSICA BIEL: You look
at me like I'm crazy.
ALAN SEALES: I just,
I never heard of it.
So I look at it like I've
never heard of the name.
JESSICA BIEL: It's
supposed to be
a place like New Paltz,
little Upstate, smallish--
I've never actually spent much
time in that particular place,
so I don't know how small.
I don't want to talk
out of turn here,
but kind of like every
place kind of a place,
you know I mean right?
Like could find this sort
of town across the country.
ALAN SEALES: It's interesting
because every place is
kind of a place, but I feel like
there are specific characters,
types of people that we see
in here that exist in all
of these every places, like
the crazy religious family
and then your small town
shop owners and what not.
Was it a conscious
decision to kind of set
the story in a place like
this, to enhance the characters
or enhance the story or does
one kind of beget the other?
JESSICA BIEL: That's
a good question.
I mean, since this is a
German writer originally,
I know it was set in
Germany somewhere.
So I think we were trying to
find a place that would serve
as the right town in the
States for, I don't know,
kind of like a place that could
have a character of its own
in a sense.
I feel like Upstate kind
of has that feeling of,
I don't know, there could be
a lot of bubbling, simmering
things going on
underneath, which
is sort of what we're talking
about in the show a little bit.
Kind of like from the outside
things are looking one way
and then when you
look a little deeper,
you're seeing something else.
I'm not trying to
like bag on Upstate,
like there's some weird
stuff going on there,
but that's true everywhere--
ALAN SEALES: Oh
we know there is.
JESSICA BIEL: --this idea
of presenting ourselves
in a certain way.
And maybe that's not
necessarily 100% true.
ALAN SEALES: I totally
agree with you.
I grew up in a small
town in North Carolina.
So same mountain chain, same
culture, just different areas.
JESSICA BIEL: There you go.
ALAN SEALES: But yeah, I
totally agree with that.
So as executive
producer, did you
help with any of the
casting of the show?
Did you have any--
JESSICA BIEL: Yes, all of it.
We have been-- it's actually
been an amazing experience.
And because I am usually
on the other side of it--
I'm the one putting
myself on tape
or going in for the
audition and having
to send these tapes that
you make at home that you're
so embarrassed about,
like oh, this is horrible.
The lighting's bad.
You're by yourself
reading with somebody
who can't read
lines because it's
like your mom and the
whole thing's bad.
I have such a love and
respect for the people
that have auditioned
for the show because
of being on the other side.
It's just so intense.
I know what they're
going through.
I know how hard it is.
And that process
has been super cool.
I just have a different
take on a reading,
on the creative
performance part of it
than, say, some of my other
producers or even our creator
or our director at the time.
So it's been amazing
and I love being
part of that, that part of it.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, I
guess now that you've
seen what it's on
the other side,
has that changed how you're
approaching new roles?
Are you even entertaining
new roles yet?
Are you still working
on finishing this one?
JESSICA BIEL: I've read
a couple of things,
but now that we're sort
of in the last stretch
of the filming, it's
like a cluster some days.
It's just everything's kind
of piling on top of itself.
So I haven't really looked
at anything seriously,
or there hasn't
really been anything
that I'm really, really excited
about, so I've been focused.
ALAN SEALES: No comedies?
JESSICA BIEL: No.
Not on purpose though.
I think it's changed
my perspective.
It just made me mad.
I'm like, I don't want
to do another audition
because they're going to
do what I'm doing when
I'm watching the audition tape.
It's like, oh, this
person is so good, but--
because when you feel like
no buts, just hire me.
I'm great.
Trust me.
I can be great for you.
ALAN SEALES: OK.
And with that note, we
have mics in the aisles.
If any of you have questions
for Jessica, line up
and we can get to those.
You are a mom now.
Congratulations.
JESSICA BIEL: Thanks.
ALAN SEALES: Yes,
Silas is 2 and 1/2.
JESSICA BIEL: Almost 2 and
1/2, yeah, two and some change.
ALAN SEALES: That's a
great age, isn't it?
JESSICA BIEL: It
is and it isn't.
It can be really great and
then it can be really terrible.
ALAN SEALES: I've got
a 2 and 1/2 year old.
I feel you.
Has being a mother in
real life influenced
how you've approached
the character of Cora
here in the center?
JESSICA BIEL: I think
just inherently yes, it
has to, because now I have an
actual understanding of what
that relationship is.
If I didn't have a
kid, yeah, of course
you can evoke as many
feelings as you can possibly
build up in your
body to understand
what that feels like.
But it will never compare
to the actual feeling of it
and the actual doing of it,
being a parent every day.
And it's like the
best research ever,
just having to
exist with your kid
everyday to understand what
it would be like, you know,
like if a person does this
kind of a thing that she does.
The trickle effect for
her life, specifically
like what happens to her
and her family and her kid
and her relationship-- does
she ever see him again?
These are big
questions when somebody
does something like this.
So I have a lot of emotions
that come up for me
when we shoot stuff
and when we deal
with the mom-child
relationship, because if I
couldn't see my kid again,
I would not make it.
I would just die on
the floor right here.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
Yeah, I hear you.
Question over here?
AUDIENCE: Hi, Jessica.
JESSICA BIEL: Hi.
AUDIENCE: It looks great.
Congratulations.
JESSICA BIEL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: It looks
really awesome.
Really excited to watch it.
So you're here,
house of YouTube.
And obviously there's
a lot of places
where people can get kind
of amazing premium content
like this.
How do you, either as an
actress or executive producer--
you've been in the
business a long time--
how do you see marketing
different nowadays
than it's been in the
past, because people
have so many options?
Love your thoughts either as an
actress or executive producer.
JESSICA BIEL: I mean you're
right, it's changed so much.
I think when I was
younger and we really
didn't have this kind of access
or these kind of platforms,
everything was dependent on
the studio or the network,
and you did everything,
and you didn't do anything.
As one of the creative
people, you just kind of did
what they told you to do and
you would go do an interview
or you would do a magazine
cover and that was kind of it.
It was very simple.
And now I feel so
much more involved.
I'm talking to USA all the time.
We're collaborating on,
what am I going to post?
What are you guys posting?
How can we push the marketing
campaign with my personal help,
with my personal platforms,
with their platforms?
It's very much more of
like a community thing.
And it's really nice
because you feel
like you have a hand in
helping to get out there.
And I guess that means you also
have a hand in if it fails,
that nobody cared and
all the stuff you did,
it didn't matter.
But at least you're part of it.
I feel much more a part of
it from the creative side.
And I guess from the
producorial standpoint,
as much help as you can
get to get the word out
for people to be talking
about your material,
talking about your
show is only helpful.
So it's been
nothing but positive
I think when it comes to
marketing, in my experience.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
JESSICA BIEL: Yeah, pleasure.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
JESSICA BIEL: Hi.
AUDIENCE: This is something
I've always wondered about.
When you're reading
something at home
and you're just to yourself,
I really like this,
I'm going to make
this into a movie,
what exactly is the process that
you get in a source material
when it does come from
a book or something
like that to be turned into
a television show or a movie?
How did that work with
this book and how does that
work in general?
JESSICA BIEL: Sure.
Bless you.
For this book I just
started reading.
And a couple chapters
in, I just was
really interested and really
intrigued and then continued on
and kept calling my partner
Michelle and saying,
have you made it to
chapter whatever yet?
You gotta get there.
It's really good.
Whoa, this went in a
direction I didn't think
that it was going to go in.
And this is a
different experience
because the material was
already owned by UCP.
So it wasn't a
situation where I had
to reach out and try to
get the rights, which we've
done multiple times before.
Honestly I will look at a
cover of something and go,
this looks interesting.
Somebody call about the
rights, like that fast,
because the rights
are just gone,
especially if it has any sort of
notoriety in the literary world
or anything at all.
If it's on anybody's list,
if it's on Oprah's list,
forget it, it's gone.
Literally I want to
be talking to authors
who haven't published yet, when
their books are on the way,
in their third, fourth,
fifth, whatever drafts.
That's when you want to
be snatching up material.
So this was a
little bit different
because UCP was
bringing it to me.
I had the opportunity to jump on
board right away, which I did.
And yeah, it's just
about your interests.
Do you like?
It is it fun?
Is there a good character here?
Is it interesting?
Is it compelling?
It's kind of as simple as that,
at least in my experience.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALAN SEALES: UCP is
Universal Cable Productions,
is that what it is?
JESSICA BIEL: Yes, UCP, yep.
ALAN SEALES: Over here?
JESSICA BIEL: Sorry,
I should have said.
AUDIENCE: All right, as
a proud owner of "Blade--
Trinity," I feel like
that actually qualifies
as a comedy at some points.
JESSICA BIEL: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: But as Jason was sort
of alluding to before about
this new era of marketing and
distribution and access points,
and TV ratings might
not be the best
way to qualify what is a
good show and a bad show
or a successful
show and not one,
I'm curious how as your
first foray into TV--
second.
I guess "7th Heaven" counts.
JESSICA BIEL: Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
Also sometimes a comedy.
ALAN SEALES: Don't look at me.
AUDIENCE: How are you looking to
gauge success for "The Sinner"
in this new world of content?
JESSICA BIEL: This is
a very good question.
I'm nervous about
this because I'm
kind of a viewer
that likes to binge.
So I want my stuff
when I want it,
as opposed to having
to wait week by week.
So I don't know how
to gauge it, honestly.
I don't know what to
expect for Wednesday night.
And if we have kind of not so
good numbers, like you said,
it doesn't necessarily mean
that the show would not have
a good viewership or following.
It may not necessarily mean that
we won't have a second season.
But I still have a bit
of an old school feeling
about it, like ugh, well if
we don't get good numbers then
I guess we'll
probably get canceled
or we won't get a second season.
I think we're going
to have to wait
when it can be
streamed to really
see what the legs of the show--
what it's going to be,
because I don't know.
I want it when I want
it, like most people do.
So it'll be really interesting
to see what happens.
I think I have to
remember to not just take
the numbers on Wednesday
as truth and that's it,
because you're right, it's
so different right now.
ALAN SEALES: Do
you watch yourself?
You going to be one of
the extra Nielsen numbers?
JESSICA BIEL: I don't know.
I mean I'll turn my
television on for sure.
I don't know.
I haven't figured that out yet.
I see my films.
But I've watched
this so many times.
I've seen these cuts a lot.
I don't think I'm going to have
a viewing party or anything.
I don't know.
I haven't really
thought about it.
ALAN SEALES: Interesting.
Yeah, I don't know if
that would be weird
or not to watch yourself on
TV-- maybe the first time.
I figure you've binged
all of "7th Heaven,"
but you're probably
over that now.
JESSICA BIEL: All
of it, oh yeah.
I just constantly go back to the
beginning and revisit it all.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, one
more question here.
AUDIENCE: Hi Jessica,
I was wondering,
who's you're favorite
actor you've worked with?
JESSICA BIEL: Favorite actor?
Oh, that's a good question.
ALAN SEALES: Your husband?
JESSICA BIEL: Have we worked
together in that capacity?
Have we?
ALAN SEALES: I don't know.
JESSICA BIEL: I don't think so.
He's really good though.
I've had the pleasure of working
with a lot of great people.
You know, Bill, Bill
Pullman and Chris
and everyone we're
working with on this
has been amazing, so much fun.
I also really loved working
on "The Illusionist"
with Ed Norton
and Paul Giamatti.
Those two guys, I mean,
they just blew me away.
They're so nice and so talented.
I mean, everyone
I've worked with
has been amazing
in their own right,
but I would say maybe
those two I really enjoyed.
AUDIENCE: Awesome, thank you.
JESSICA BIEL: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Cool.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So you know when you base
something off a book,
be it a movie or a TV
show, inevitably there
are going to be some changes.
Usually the plot gets different
or some things are being cut
or some things are being added.
And I guess two questions.
Firstly, how loosely did
you base it off the book?
Like is it very
accurate or did you
get a lot of creative
license with it?
And secondly, how do you
make those decisions?
How do you decide what is in
and what is not and what to add?
JESSICA BIEL: Right,
good questions.
So we stick pretty closely to
kind of the main real threads
of this book.
This book kind of lives in
two worlds, a present time
and a past.
And so there's these threads
that we're kind of following.
And we take some
creative liberties,
I think, mainly
with the characters.
I don't even know if you
call them creative liberties.
We just develop them
in a different way,
maybe a little bit more
thoroughly in some ways,
a little bit broader
in other ways,
took some really acute
ideas of these characters
and expanded it a little bit.
But we stick pretty closely
to the main big plot points.
For example, the Ambrose
character, Bill Pullman's
character, he's much
different in our show
than he is in the book.
Cora--
ALAN SEALES: Did you
write him that way
or did Bill choose
to take him that way?
JESSICA BIEL: We
wrote it that way.
I think me and my
producers and our creator,
Derek Simonds, who's
an incredible writer
and developer, he really saw
that that Ambrose character
needed more behind it,
needed to really flush out
this person for television.
So he took that liberty
and changed that character.
The second question was--
can you remind me?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, how do you go
about making the decisions?
JESSICA BIEL: Oh,
making the decisions.
You know, that's a tough
one because you obviously
want to keep the skeleton
and the real flavor,
the language of the book,
because you're optioning
this material for a reason.
But the formats are
so different, right?
You can sit and read this book
for days and days and days
and just slowly get chunks
and be very happy with it,
whereas what we're trying to
do is keep your attention,
keep an audience's
interest for--
I think it's what, 42
minutes with commercials--
short attend attention spans.
We have to kind of
drop little nuggets
along the way to keep you
interested and keep you going.
So we really have to
cut things and add
things to keep that in mind,
to keep the suspense moving.
Whereas you could read
a book and it's just
like interesting and
romantic and atmospheric,
but nothing really happens for
a while and you're cool with it.
That doesn't work
obviously in television.
But the main person who's
making these decisions
is Derek, our writer-creator.
And we are trusting him to
know that this is the best
way to handle all of these
interweaving storylines, arcs,
themes, past, present, time.
It's very complicated what
we've been having to do.
And how he's been doing has
been quite an amazing feat.
So hopefully you will agree.
ALAN SEALES: Cool.
We are actually short on time.
I know you have to get going.
So is there a quick
question over here?
Got time for one more?
AUDIENCE: Hopefully.
ALAN SEALES: OK, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So we already started
touching on this briefly.
Are you ever sitting
at your house looking
at source material and you and
Justin just look at each other
and you're like, hey, we
should do this together.
Or have you talked about
it throughout your lives
like we should do
this or, hey, I'd
love for you to kill me in this?
JESSICA BIEL: He would
probably love that.
Yes, all the time, all
the time we are looking--
I'm reading something going,
you know, you should read this.
There's a really interesting
character in here for you.
Or yes, we should try to
do something together.
What would it be?
I always say to him that it
would be fun to do something
where like not playing lovers or
not playing married people, do
something completely, I don't
know, something not that.
I don't know what
that would mean.
ALAN SEALES: Comedian assassins.
JESSICA BIEL:
Yeah, there you go.
ALAN SEALES: That would be fun.
JESSICA BIEL: That would
be fun, So yeah, we're
always looking for that
right thing, because why not?
Why not work with your best
friend, partner person,
if you can?
But I really think you have to
be careful because we've all
seen this go terribly wrong.
You know what I'm talking about.
[LAUGHTER]
There's a few of them
that I'm talking about.
So it's a delicate
balance of finding
the right thing, of being at
the right time of your lives.
And I don't know, we
haven't found it yet.
But I hope so.
I hope we can.
I'd love to work with them.
Actually you know what, we talk
a lot about him directing me
in something, which I
think would be really
cool because he's directed a
few things, like little things,
commercials and
different things.
And he basically does a lot
with his own videos and stuff
like that.
But I really think he'd
be an amazing filmmaker.
So I'd love for him to
direct me in something.
So now it's out there,
and he better do it,
because I'm the boss of him.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: All right, so cool.
We have this little Android for
you as thank you for coming in.
It's a Talks at Google Android.
JESSICA BIEL: Thank you.
ALAN SEALES: Everyone go see--
watch "The Sinner" this
Wednesday, August 2 on USA.
And help me thank Jessica
Biel for coming in.
JESSICA BIEL: Thank you guys.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN SEALES: Thank you.